what up space fam goals in here from
anime opera back at it again to discuss
the latest and craziest developments in
the one piece story in this chapter one
piece has done the unthinkable sanji is
undergoing an insane and dark
transformation we see big mom's true
power awaken and much more so make sure
to stay tuned for this one if you do
enjoy these one-piece reviews and want
to keep them coming you know what to do
channel the pirate king within and smash
that like button remember smashing that
like button is pirate king energy and
passing is orochi energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video you subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future one-piece videos and updates
that's just the way it works and while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my huge and
growing one-piece playlist that includes
videos on all the yonko warlords
supernova and much more link to that is
in the description and now without
further ado let's jump into its spoilers
and all we get a color spread this time
around of a bunch of right hand men
including zorro in the center we see
king the dark king marco and more it's a
great idea and i love the idea of giving
the first mates a space to shine like
this it also reminds us of just how cool
the right hand men tend to be the
chapter is called soldier of science
which we can assume with all the germa
stuff happening that is referencing to
sanji but first we start where we left
off with big mom being crushed by the
beams some bystanders even comment that
not even big mom could survive that of
course they are wrong but it's
significant that law and kid managed to
pull off an attack against a yonko that
looked definitive law and kit are shown
and they are exhausted and panting i
love how kid can barely move and says
take that you giant hag they actually
let their guard down for a bit and start
up a conversation and it's perfect law
starts questioning kit about his
awakening saying it allows him to assign
fields of attraction but wonders how
long it lasts i absolutely love it when
kid dodges the question asking why would
he tell law that this makes perfect
sense after all despite working together
right now they are rivals and kid
doesn't want to reveal all his tricks to
a guy he could be warring against down
the line after all we've seen how
competitive luffy kit and law can get
but then big mom appears lifting herself
and the steel beams above her she truly
looks like a monster when you see her
silhouette although none of us should be
shocked the bystanders are she asks for
life or oshiruko aka red bean soup and
then she proceeds to take life from the
bystanders giving life to new homies
that's business as usual for big mom but
what's truly crazy is that she even uses
one year of her lifespan because none of
the riff raff as she calls them have
powerful enough souls she consumes that
year of her life at once and she gets
even bigger she looks like such a
satisfying final boss in this panel as
her bigger than giant self towers over
law and kid this could potentially be
viewed as a type of awakening for big
mom's power as she can sacrifice years
of her life to become insanely stronger
than she was which is a big deal when
the starting point is as strong as it is
but perhaps even more surprising than
the new op form is that kit and law made
her sacrifice a year of her life to use
it she's already 68 so she'd now be like
69 and that's assuming she hasn't used
the ability before which is not even a
logical assumption keep in mind
whitebeard was 72 when he died and he
was definitely weakened by age at that
point so big mom burning up her already
limited years like this is not a good
sign for the longevity of the current
yonko system super saiyan big mom goes
on to say that it's been decades since
she's felt pain like this that's at
least 20 years we're talking about which
is truly insane she even sparred with
kaido without resorting to this form
relatively recently albeit they probably
weren't too serious but it's still
notable that these two brought out a
form that clashing with kaido didn't and
she felt worse pain too ironically i
viewed the appearance of this new op
form of big moms as a big win for our
supernovas big mom even acknowledges
them which is always an awesome moment
she says u-runs aren't bad trafalgar law
captain kidd the two of you and straw
hat luffy are serious about taking our
thrones bring it on if you think you
have a shot i'll show you what it means
to be an emperor end quote this is such
a great exciting moment by oda i can't
wait to see how kit and law behave
against an even stronger big mom after
they supposedly just used their
awakenings that should have all but
depleted their stamina already things
don't look good and that's how the best
fights tend to look anyways before
they're over but respect to law and kids
who are still standing their ground law
says i'll need to take down monsters
like you if i ever want to uncover the
true history and that angle makes law
unique but to me personally it is a bit
anticlimactic compared to the ambitions
of his fellow worst generation captains
who want to take the thrones of the
yonko and become the pirate king but you
do you law it's clear though from oda's
writing here that law won't be a big
rival to luffy for pirate king since he
seems to value a different end goal more
namely uncovering the true history that
being said it's also a good news because
it might mean we get to see more law law
and luffy will be able to work alongside
each other better in the future if both
of their main reasons for being aren't
to become the one and only pirate king
kid for his part says no more holding
back we're going all out which in and of
itself is very interesting because if
that wasn't going all out what else do
they have to offer it's very exciting to
find out then he continues i don't give
a damn what it costs i'm gonna tear her
from that throne end quote that's much
more of a pirate king energy thing to
say than what law said obviously kid
can't become pirate king because that's
our protagonist's fate but hopefully the
rivalry will be fun to watch and kid
will still become a legendary pirate
captain in his own right as the samurai
forces fight against the beast forces
they feel like they are in hell the
castles become an inferno and the giant
monster that is an even bigger big mom
is hovering over them oda has given us
quite an amazing setting and atmosphere
here we then jump back to drake and appu
i said last time that how drake proceeds
here will tell us a lot about his
character apu made a lot of sense when
he was saying it doesn't serve drake or
the marines for them to fight here the
average marine would have seen the
wisdom in his words but drake appears to
have more of that kobe energy he feels
the need to repay straw hat by finishing
up buu off which raises my esteem for
his character i feel like there's a
natural bias against marines but drake
looks like he's going to be one of the
exceptions like kobe and garf he's not
just doing what the marines want he's
following his own moral compass and
that's always respectable it appears
like drake is going to win too he's
figured out how abu's attacks work and
apu even needs to resort to saying he
has the numbers that can help him
clearly not confident in his own powers
but then yamato starts running through
the scene apu is as slippery as ever
trying to warm up to yamato this time
but she has no time to chat she even
attacks drake saying don't get in my way
only for drake to tell her he's
abandoned kaido too it's hilarious how
yamato just says my bad and keeps
running as drake is knocked to the
ground you gotta love yamato then fuga
one of the numbers starts chasing after
yamato let me know what you guys think
that's gonna be about looks like these
numbers might finally come into play in
a significant way apu tells the
remaining two numbers to follow him but
drake reminds him that he's not going to
let his fellow supernova get away again
the marines would not approve of this
time wasting with apu especially for the
sake of strawhat but for drake it makes
sense in the meantime cp 0 is no longer
playing go and is actively chasing down
robin you see them in the distance as
brook calls them formidable robin tells
brook that even among the elites of cp0
the mast agents are in their own class
and rob lucci doesn't wear a mask so
make up that statement what you will if
they are so strong though brook and
robin will need help perhaps from the
straw hats who finish their fights like
frankie and jinbe we'll have to wait and
see what happens i have no doubt that
brook will have more chances to shine
here but expecting him to deal with both
of these next level guys is asking a
whole lot we then jump to the shocking
and unthinkable event it's hard to
believe that it's actually come to this
but it actually appears that sanji hurt
a woman in the pleasure hall he's being
identified as a rebel and being accused
of hurting one of the young girls sanji
says he could never do that but they say
he was alone with her and that they just
want to hide in peace so the assumption
is that sanji hurt a non-combatant young
girl this is about as anti-sanji as you
can get and really horrifying it doesn't
seem like sanchi at all however he's not
sure he didn't do it he recalls being
shocked at his brothers hurting a woman
and now it seems he might be capable of
the same thing queen is just like in the
background of sanji's existential crisis
here laughing and saying random stuff
like the pleasure hall is closed you
germ adult as if sanji was just popping
in for some pleasure in the middle of a
battle honestly i can see why queen is
laughing that would be hilarious but
back to sanji and the existential crisis
he notices the tingling sensation
stopped so wonders if the transformation
is over sanji recalls being lost in
thought he ran into the girl who was a
geisha from the flower capital it could
not look worse for sanji she told him
kaido's men brought her here but she's
not with them she was unharmed and we
saw sanji's face looking emotionless she
begged not to be hurt and the next thing
sanji knew she was on the floor bleeding
it is very incriminating stuff here if
it was just a pleasure woman saying he
did it i obviously wouldn't believe it
but sanji's face and the loss of memory
with all the other evidence is very
incriminating he even says she had a
terrified look in her eyes when she was
apparently looking at him this is some
very dark stuff and i honestly never
thought sanji would go through it could
it all be explained away somehow perhaps
but that would sort of undermine the
struggle here the fact that sanji is
losing himself against his will suddenly
the fact that he couldn't fight maria
earlier on the series the moment that
many fans were upset about makes a lot
more sense oda purposely added that
situation in earlier so that this part
would be all the more significant then
sanji starts truly wondering what
version of himself is better for luffy
for his captain he himself points out
that his human side is worthless against
female enemies which as we saw can be
very inconvenient if not outright
annoying but as a soldier of science the
title of the chapter he'd be able to
execute anyone luffy ordered him to even
queen would be easy to dismember that is
very big talk not to mention a huge flex
this is kaido's second strongest fighter
and sanji is implying here if he flipped
the soldier of science switch on he
could make quick work of him it's
definitely very tempting for those of us
who love power upgrades but oda is doing
a fantastic job of showing that even in
shonen power is not everything some
things are more important sanji is not
sure what kind of person the pirate king
needs by his side but he decides to
destroy the suit that awaken his dormant
augmented abilities he decides he's not
gonna lose any more of himself he'll
never belong to germa so it's like the
anti-sasuke decision since sasuke was
pretty much willing to do anything to
get stronger still since the powers are
already awakened it's not clear whether
destroying the suit even matters at this
point but it's symbolic for showing that
consciously sanji chooses himself over
germa power meanwhile queen could not
care less about our boy's deep
contemplations and is just upset that he
won't get to see him use the suit
hilariously sanji says farewell germa
and women's baths he'll find his own way
to finish this fight i'm guessing he's
referring to the fact that he can't use
the suit's invisibility to spy on women
anymore things sanji is willing to give
up for his principles you gotta respect
the dude then we have an absolutely
amazing exchange between sanji and zorro
definitely one of my favorite things
about this chapter zoro randomly notices
the transponder snail as he's fighting
king he wonders where it came from and
sanji hilariously points out he slipped
it in just in case zoro got lost that's
perfect zorro tells the dumb cook to use
his words that he's distracting him he
is fighting kaido's right hand man after
all so sanji gets their point saying
we're going to beat the beast pirates to
which zoro says obviously that moment in
of itself is great but it keeps going
sanji is clearly not sure what sort of
person he'll become if he goes all out
against queen and so he says if he's no
longer himself will zoro put him down
zoro is confused but not needing much of
an explanation says fine he'll make it
swift if it comes to that and then as
the cherry on top of this awesome
conversational cake zorro says now i've
got some to look forward to so that
means you better not die before then and
sanji says thanks i love how while
insulting each other while pretending
like they hate each other's guts these
guys can show how much they care about
each other at the same time sanji
launches an attack that sends queen
flying and the narrator says it shows
his resolve sanji is about to become a
beast during this battle not having to
worry about what he becomes afterwards
since he can rely on zorro to stop him
loves seeing the understanding and trust
between these two and i've never been
more interested to see what happens with
sanji's character how opie is he going
to be here and how is he going to turn
out character-wise after this fight
anyways that is it for this insane
chapter it's crazy to think about how
much oda packed in here as usual let me
know what you thought of this chapter
and what you're expecting to happen in
the next one also drop your mvp in the
comments below as usual if you do enjoy
seeing these one-piece reviews and want
to keep them coming you know what to do
channel the pirating within and smash
that like button remember smashing that
like button is pyroking energy and
passing is orochi energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video subscribe and this is crucial hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates that's just
the way it works and while you wait for
the next chapter to drop feel free to
check out my huge and growing one piece
playlist that includes videos on all the
yonko warlords admirals and much more
link to that is in the description and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
my
you